-You know our next guest
from NBC's "The Office"
and films such as
"Pineapple Express"
and "This Is the End."
He hosts "The Masked Dancer,
which premieres Sunday,
December 27th, on Fox.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Craig Robinson,
everybody.
-Hey! What's happening?
-Oh, my God.
-How are you doing?
-I'm doing -- Craig, oh, my God,
it's so good to see you.
I can't -- I can't help
but notice
I'm featured on the wall
there behind you.
-It's good to see you, buddy
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah, yeah,
these are my Seth Meyers
high school/college
photo travel posters.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, I don't think -
I think we printed, let's see,
I think 20,000 of those
and only sold the one.
[ Laughter ]
-These guys, they help
with, you know, anxiety.
You know, there's a lot of
anxiety in the world right now
These guys calm me down, man
They all have
their own personality.
-Based on those, you must be
happy that I'd been growin
the hair longer
during these trying times?
-Bro, the episode where you,
at the very end
of "Closer Look,"
where you had the white suit
and you were being James Spader.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God!
First of all, it was
second-to-second brillianc
but at the end,
"This has been 'A Closer Look.'"
Dude, people don't know --
people don't talk about
Seth Meyers enough, all of
the talents you got, man.
You go in to any voice.
-Oh, you are a fan of -- see
I would say I'm a very middl
of the road impressionist,
but this is very kind.
That's very kind.
-No, no, you do them good, man
Give me Giuliani.
Give me Giuliani!
-[ as Rudy Giuliani ] See,
I don't think my Giuliani
is particularly good.
-Mitch McConnell.
-[ as Mitch McConnell ]
Oh, lovely to have
Mr. Craig Robinson here.
[ Laughter ]
-Lindsey Graham.
-[ as Lindsey Graham ]
You know, I'm --
I'm very troubled
by the fact that --
where'd he get
those pictures of Seth Meyers?
-Evil German voice!
-[ German accent ] Mr. Robinson,
we are very happy you're here.
[ Laughter ]
But we do have some question
about your masks.
-Bernie Sanders!
-[ as Bernie Sanders ]
It's very troubling for me
-Dennis Miller!
-[ as Dennis Miller ] Crai
Robinson on the other hand
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, okay, okay, you win
You don't get enough credit,
homes.
-[ Normal voice ]
Thank you, my friend.
You are my friend!
-Look, I love the sea captain.
-See, now, this is good to hea
'cause nobody gives
the sea captain any respect.
-But the quarantine duck.
Oh!
-Well, see.
-That was -- That was the one.
-So Ira -- see, you know,
I feel as though
we can bring Ira back
in the new year
because we did establish
he's from Brooklyn,
and there's no reason why he
couldn't join us in the studio
-Please bring him back.
Also, I Googled the movie,
"Internal Issues,"
and it hasn't been made!
-[ Laughs ]
-It's our name now!
[ Laughter ]
It could be a movie, a podcast
a band, a super power.
-This is --
-"Internal Issues," man.
-As interviews go,
this is my favorite ever.
[ Laughter ]
-Aluminium!
-Craig, this is so kind,
but I want to talk
about you too.
I mean --
-Wait, wait.
How did the rabbit thing go?
Hopping up to the kids?
-Oh, okay, so for those
who aren't
Craig Robinson-level fans
of the show,
my dad said he was going
to visit --
the next time he visited my kids
because they like
the white rabbit
in "Alice in Wonderland,"
he was going to dress up
like the white rabbit
and, Craig, you mentioned this
so we wanted to let you know
exactly how it went.
Boom. Look at that man.
Look at him!
-Wow!
-[ Laughs ]
-What a nice family, man,
good for you, good for you
-How have you been through this?
Are you staying healthy
through quarantine?
I remember you saying
you're a vegan.
Are you still a vegan?
-I had Popeye's chicken today.
[ Laughter ]
So today I wasn't.
But I've been --
yeah, I've been working out,
going to the park and stuff.
I started writing a musical.
-That's great.
That's right in your wheelhouse.
-Yeah, yeah.
"Jersey Goys."
-Oh, boy.
-But look here.
[ Laughter ]
It hasn't been done yet!
"Internal Issues"!
-Oh, oh, wait, I have
something else.
Now, this is very exciting
"Masked Dancer"
is very exciting.
It makes sense
you'd be doing it.
You were a contestant on
"The Masked Singer."
Don't take this the wrong way.
I feel like you were
the fastest guest person
ever on the show, yes?
-I wasn't a contestant.
I was a guest host.
-That makes more sense.
-I hadn't watched the show
before I got to be
the guest host,
and now, I'm hooked on it
and I can't wait for peopl
to get
hooked on "Masked Dancer."
-Now, this was you
in a mask, Craig.
And I feel like, compared to
a lot of the masks on the show
this is not
a lot of face coverage.
-Yeah, it's just some cardboar
with some eye holes poked in it.
[ Laughter ]
-People just --
People knew right away.
And now, though, this is -
I'm guessing
on "The Masked Dancer,"
does it --
is it harder to guess people
Because you're not hearing
their voice, right?
-I think so.
It's hard for me
to guess the singers.
So, I think so, even though,
had I been watching the show
I would have known
Patti LaBelle's voice.
-Sure.
-So, but what they do,
they give you extra clues, okay,
in the clue package,
and then when the --
there's clues
in the dance routine,
and then there's also,
they remove
the voice modulation,
so you get to hear one wor
from the character.
And that word is also a clue
So, it's hard, but they make i
so if you're watching,
you can follow along.
-Now, this show,
both "The Masked Singer"
and I'm assuming
"The Masked Dancer,"
these are very joyous affairs.
Yet, the secrecy
is taken very seriously.
Like, when one of
the contestants comes in,
they take great steps
to keep them anonymous, yes?
-They -- When they get to set,
they have on a black hoodi
that they can see through,
obviously, but you can't see
They have a shirt that says,
"don't talk to me."
No one is allowed, you know,
they go in their trailer,
they're there all day.
They take two or three cars.
I think they ride in the trunk
If you ever need a body hidden
talk to the people
at "Masked Dancer" and "Singer."
They are good with the secrecy
-Are you a good dancer, Craig?
I'm going to jump to
the conclusion that you are.
-Maybe you don't remember
a party we attended,
a post-"SNL" party.
Oh. Oh.
-[ Laughs ]
-Anyway.
I don't think that happened.
But, look, I am a good dancer.
I have some strong moves.
Not a lot of strong moves
anymore, but, you know,
I got this one that's kind o
a step mixed with salsa,
and the funny thing about it
Seth,
is I don't know
that I'm going to do it.
I never think
about doing that move.
So, when the music hits me
right, that's when it comes ou
and I start, you know,
it's really -- it's interesting.
-This is very exciting
for the good people at Peacock
They're about to get
"The Office,"
which I don't need to tell you
is more popular now
than it's ever been.
-Peacock!
-[ Laughs ]
-But I think other people
are maybe a little upset
because it's -- you know,
in order for this to happen,
it's coming down off
of other streamers,
and people are reaching ou
to you to see
if you can do
something about this.
Correct?
-Oh, yes.
There's one person on Instagra
that keeps contacting me,
saying,
"Please don't let them tak
'The Office' off of Netflix.
And, you know,
I want to answer back,
but I kind of like them
thinking I have that power
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, they're saying
like every couple --
I don't know how many --
every couple of weeks maybe.
Please don't take "The Office,
and she said it to me like
I'm doing it.
"Please don't take
'The Office' off of Netflix.
I don't have anything to d
with that, ma'am.
[ Laughter ]
If Peacock...
Peacock is getting it.
-[ Laughs ]
I want to --
I mean, it must be so rewardin
that people continue
to find "The Office" --
I feel like it's a show
that, one, people who watched it
when it first came out
continue to watch it.
Young people find it
all the time
and love it as much
as anyone ever did.
How -- And it just
must be fantastic
to have been a part of thi
thing that has endured so long
-They never paid me.
[ Laughter ]
It was -- it was a dream
that you -- a dream come true.
But the interesting thing
about me being on "The Office,
I love deadpan humor.
Like, my guys are like
Leslie Nielsen,
and Peter Sellers,
Harvey Korman,
you know what I'm saying,
the deadpan comedian, right?
Love it.
Something crazy is going on,
and you're just acting lik
nothing's happening.
So, "Office" is all deadpan,
right?
I saw the English version
on a plane one time.
I don't know
how I came across it.
Loved it.
Didn't see it.
Then saw a picture of Davi
Brent on the side of a 7-Eleven.
I was like, "Oh."
I figured out how to watch -
I was like, "Okay, BBC,"
yada, yada,
and then fell in love
with the show
and then ended up, you know, i
came around, did the audition,
and it was like, "Be deadpan,"
what have you.
It just was like serendipitous
for my life.
-You're so good in that.
You're the best thing
in "Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
I say that as a dear frien
of Andy Samberg,
but you just blow him
out of the water
every time you're
on stage with him.
Every time you're on scree
with him.
-Bro, the --
we're like two 5-year-olds
You ever see two kids just
meeting and just start playing
-Yeah.
-That's what it is.
-Man, if Samberg is acting
like a 5-year-old,
he's grown up
since I last saw him.
[ Laughter ]
It is always so good to see you,
Craig.